people of the internet retro reckon tour
here just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and we are live with
Spider-Man Miles Morales our first time
playing through this game Let's Dive In
I mean already
I was just talking with the chat here
before we got started how incredible
this game looks
and we did switch it over to Performance
mode so we're gonna be getting the best
frame rate and we are also playing on
the PS5 as well
this is Luna Comics welcome in
thank you for being here Luna
I love you guys too
[Music]
Rio Morales or city council
foreign
[Music]
yeah I just could not get over them
subtitles
where'd they go
I got you
hey thanks no problem
hey uh you think you're gonna add that
new Spiderman too the kid yeah maybe
original is just my guy you know yeah I
know
is
Bodega around here yeah bright yellow
sign down the block can't miss
thanks beautiful work by the way
maybe leave a little room for the new
guy just in case
how did it all right
how did the subtitles get turned off we
specifically oh I think I backed out
though
I think I backed out to the main menu
all right turn them back on now
purple VR welcome in welcome in Cloud
Roth you could see me be secretly being
Spider-Man
dude my kids love Spider-Man
you guys talking about Green Goblin
though that is my my youngest loves
Venom and loves him some Green Goblin
which let's be honest right as kids
didn't we all love I mean Venom's kind
of like that anti-hero
free Goblin is just he's just pretty bad
but
oh man it's been so long since I played
this uh the original
going back to the raft real good the
rat's an eyesore it's secure you they
absolutely nailed
web slinging in this let's hope
closing in on you be there soon
come on no I'll be late
did you get the shopping list hey Mom oh
yeah Green Goblin feels like spider m
gonna check a store downtown oh thank
you but avoid Midtown that prison Convoy
is making traffic and Nightmare oh yeah
good call see you at dinner mom
man how does Pete do this secret
identity thing completely stresses me
out
dude don't they have the actual like
Miles Morales from the
from uh into the spider-verse I think
they have that skin
in this
and
what they did they actually gave you the
option to be cool helping Spider-Man
protect you you could like lower the
frame rate you can handle this
just on Miles when you're wearing that
suit it looks so awesome
I mean normally I'm all about the frames
but when you do that it makes it look
so close to the movie it's crazy
how are you
drinking very carefully wait okay go
time
heavy payload copy Helix 2 we've got you
on scope this is a big operation It's
gotta be hundreds of felons escaped from
the raft last year now it's time to move
them back in police aren't taking any
chances especially not with our guest of
honor
those guys who helped doc doctors in
there think so could be vulture it could
be scorpion could be no Goblin yet
problem
s
Spider-Man's your favorite superhero GG
he's in my top two
can't decide between him and Batman
for me for me personally
oh man it is starting off
oh man starting off with explosions
all right who's in there they said
someone bigger so
maybe rhino
Helix 2 is down no casualties payload
compromise Response Team dispatched
side Helix too I'm sorry man I didn't
mean to it's okay we got this
just need to contain it before
oh
before that happens
oh it is Rhino
[Music]
all right
oh great
come on oh my gosh dude it's been so
long since I
I'm trying to remember the combat
okay circle is Dodge
oh wait wait I do remember okay L1 and
R1
right then
yeah they throw the stuff nearby
I'm glad they're recapping the controls
because I completely forgot
[Music]
uh Dodge to the side tap R1 repeatedly
okay that's it's coming back to me it's
coming back to me
down to heal
yeah
the Triple A easy whole new career
let's use these from over here
just shot me
never see the big guy up close like this
will work hard all right I thought there
was a way to pull the weapon out of
their hand that that may be an upgrade
that I don't have yet
okay see like that guy's got a gun over
there
thought it was whole triangle
oh yeah I did there we go
you just have to hold it down
your favorite is uh Batman and Green
Arrow
for Marvel always Spider-Man
that dude trying to take the selfie
for those of you who played this how
long is this game by the way I've heard
it's a pretty short overall experience
for Miles Morales that's not good
oh
wait L2 R2
oh yeah I do remember that the point
launch thing is awesome
[Applause]
Dodge
oh we're close to him can I just drop on
him
work together
I'm giving you your hand up here
yeah I got you
hey I'm gonna check the performance mode
here in a second too make sure it didn't
switch
[Music]
avoid obstacles okay
not really sure where they want us to go
we're just trying to avoid people I
guess
[Music]
this is crazy dude
oh I hit the wrong button I hit X though
just in time
[Music]
nice Spider-Man nice
he's a menace yeah
he's up low energy Menace
about 10 hours Daniel gotcha
very fast at us
it is relatively short
but they did it was uh it was cheaper if
I remember
wait where'd he go where'd he go
where'd he go
mom you're distracting me
I can't focus
[Music]
yeah yeah what do we do let us raise
temperature
oh man man very bad
[Music]
oh my gosh
Pete are you okay
dude Rhino is just going crazy
oh yeah I cannot wait for the new
Wolverine game too
that's Insomniac right
can't wait to see what they do with that
thank you
oh
all right let me check this real quick
settings
visual dude I knew it switched back to
Fidelity I was like this does not feel
like
changing the setting will require
restarting the last checkpoint
you think that's a checkpoint
I'm doing it
yeah oh my gosh it's night and day dude
night and day
I'm also gonna put on why did it change
just because I backed out to the main
menu earlier it completely reset
everything
I could tell such a big difference
though it's like wait a second this does
not look smooth
Convoy next time I'm telling you man I'm
just so used to 60 FPS at this point
pretty good
come on
there we go
yeah just hold triangle and you can
remove their
weapons
it is in some yeah I thought so
all right let's see what's the quickest
way to get up there
yeah there we go
it's it's slowly coming back to me man
because the controls
are so good in this game it's so fluid
hitting a 15 times combo earns you the
ability to perform a finisher build a 15
times combo by attacking or dodging
without getting hit okay
there we go got the finisher on him
where is the other guy oh there's a
bunch over here
yo Nico with the five gifted memberships
Nico thank you so much dude
guys if you got one of those gifted
memberships make sure you thank Nico and
you also get access to all of our
Channel emotes now
and special role in Discord as well it's
a great way to support the streams
appreciate it Nico good to see you here
tonight man
hang on
shout out to Nico guys Nico does a lot
of work in our Discord for us in
addition to
moderating during the live streams
now let's see who uh Gigi got one Izzy
got one Luis Brittany and moonlace all
just got a gifted membership from Nico
right there
you're a wizard you're a wizard Harry
all right looks like they want us to go
down here
not gonna electrocute me right
Spiderman you good
Pete
wake up
wake us wake up man
wake up man
oh no
this Spiderman is he actually gone
I would like to exchange for new one
ah
exchange for the new one
my ass get out of here okay he's good
he's good
oh yeah he has like a special ability in
this game doesn't he well I mean in
general he has slightly different
abilities than
traditional Spider-Man
the Peter Parker Venom punch okay L1
plus Square oh my gosh Venom punch
causes Venom stun on impact Venom
stunned enemies take bonus damage from
basic attacks okay so we hit him with
that L1 Square
and then we could just punch him
normally now
yeah there we go
inside a fluid induction
you survive while you're mentorism
I want to grab this over here
oh wait we got we still have the punch
is it just unlimited right here
we do have it again
I think they're giving us it's kind of
like a little tutorial so they're giving
it to us
unlimited times
all right
oh here we go with this again
okay I definitely don't have it right
now
now we've got it
I don't know how we get it actually
yikes okay let's heal let's heal
[Music]
oh I lost the Venom
en I'm infused
yeah
okay there we go
I'm not sure if it's just a time thing
or what
you destroyed
like right there we got it back really
quick
[Music]
[Applause]
got it back again
yeah it looks like it's giving it to us
when we hit him when we Dodge just about
for anything oh and we totally died
right there
wait we actually died right there
you can't really do much when you don't
have that punch
yeah see right there
oh it was too far away
okay yeah even that web right there
there we go
all right man no more breakouts please
don't you care oh come on
and then when you get hit it completely
takes it away
all right we got it again
so yeah basically anything just don't
get hit
and you'll build it back up
yeah Luna you're right it definitely
goes away when you get hit
yeah
taking you to the city oh wow see like
that time we got it back for
is dodging a couple times
dodging and a couple webs right there oh
finish your finisher finisher
you live calendar
kinda
yeah I was gonna say if they go with the
spider Spider-Man Miles Morales
storyline
or uh into the spider-verse that's what
I was thinking of
guys
wow just wow
Simon Krieger head of r d at roxon
energy
pleasure to meet you you too uh sorry I
think our ball landed in your yard no I
actually did us a favor aren't we all
right tear down for a build
but uh looks like you beat us to it
I wanted to thank you both of you
taken down rhino
solo
you are going places bud
thanks but he's still dangerous nah I
will
hold him for the police you know I
always think these Super Troopers are
Overkill until
like this happens nope Judy calls hey uh
really great to meet you both
Future's looking bright
he's right
let's clear out
let the police do their job
yeah
yeah okay
bioelectricity
how to be honest I'm so jealous hey
hello sharing a pizza up there and on
the OG I think we should run tests
tomorrow
a little voltage analysis oh man yeah
sorry I've been meaning to tell you hey
Dylan with the five gifted sir
this is some kind of pee joke I don't
get
no uh MJS
and requested me as her photographer
kind of a working vacation for us oh man
you're a wizard Harry I don't know if
I'm ready to fly solo I screwed up today
big time with the helicopter but then
you delivered big time you've saved my
bacon miles
hey I did this gig for eight years
without backup and you better believe I
screwed up lots of times
but that is how you learn
you're a wizard Harry what's this
Christmas present
but first
you gotta take the oath oh
um okay
I promise to do everything in my power
to protect this city
I promise
that's it
that oh the real thing
totally definitely didn't just make it
up
see you in a few weeks Spiderman
New York's only Spiderman okay so that's
how they're explaining him
why miles is gonna be so low
by the way Dylan thank you so much for
those five gifteds uh Ryan Simeon guwop
little paveo
and Kavon Thompson all just got gifted a
membership from Dylan appreciate the
support Dylan and guys you uh you have
access to the emotes now and also a
special role in our Discord as well as
access to some behind the scenes videos
that we have been doing recently it's
behind the scenes members only vlogs
YouTube has it set up where you can post
videos that only members can see so I've
been experimenting a bit with that too
oh here we go
yes
oh this music
well we just upgraded a ton right there
all right press touchpad to access the
skill tree
uh you have leveled up and earned a
skill point skill points are awarded
when you gain enough experience points
XP
complete missions and defeat enemies to
gain XP and earn more skill points
highlight a skill and hold X to unlock
the skill
okay here we go so we've got Venom
skills combat skills question marks
all right so the combat skills let's see
increases the rate of bioelectric power
generation from attacking and dodging
raising the amount in the Venom bar that
would be pretty useful to have
uh press L1 plus square plus X to
perform a Venom smash that will damage
and Venom stuns surrounding enemies
oh Brittany that sounds so good I had
pizza for lunch today
can I do any of these I guess they all
cost the same oh no I see level three
oh that's level three two no way okay so
this is the only one we can get right
now
we have to do this to we have to do this
one Venom smash can now be viewed in the
moves list
all right and we just have we've got
more skill points
and it says level
level three and level five so I don't
think we can do those yet
yeah see up here in the top right we
still have more
this one right here allows a third
finisher to be banked unlocked and New
Game Plus no way
all right so let's take a look at our
missions here hold on to your web
shooters
oh this is the active one all right
yo Genki dude
rhino
what yeah where you at you get into the
apartment okay yeah everyone this is a
good spot for the webcam too
floor and now I'm in the park grabbing
some air oh perfect dip over to the
amphitheater got something to show you
dude is this spider related
he's telling me you've got a piece of
rhinos horn or something
a piece of rhinos horn
[Music]
miles can perform a variety of Tricks
while in air holds Square
oh I see
I see I see
it's just like in Hogwarts man how it's
so fun in Hogwarts to fly around on the
Broom
same thing in Spider-Man just so fun to
swing around
my favorite Spider-Man Toby Andrew or
Tom
oh that's tough
I mean I grew up with the Toby Maguire
movies
but I feel like Tom Holland is
oh man
like Toby is what I think of just
because I grew up with those but I might
like
Tom's better
and I don't feel like Andrew really got
a chance I mean he didn't get to play
him
as much as the others Christmas present
from Spider-Man
open it
dude put it on I'll cover you
oh is this a suit
let's go
is it the black one I've never seen a
guy change clothes in Central Park
okay
how's it looking
oh it's actually his
one of his first ones
[Music]
oh here we go dude you've unlocked a new
suit suits can be equipped through the
suits menu in the suits page come back
here when you have unlocked more suits
or if you want to switch out your
current suit
of this amazing gift
head Uptown for part two
oh wait so we do
oh yes there it is the into the
spider-verse suit
oh wait so we already have this one too
the advanced Tech
all right so we got the track suit oh
man that is fire right there dude that
is fire
but there's just something about
the into the spider-verse one man
I'm gonna put this one on
and I'm gonna see if it actually uh
I'll show you guys what I was talking
about the frame rate thing what's the
other half if it doesn't let you know
when I find it
oh no it's not doing it right now I
think it's it must be some setting that
you have to change
with the most okay Jonah Jameson what
this Pete said it suits to autoplay
Jameson's show guys a masochist
my Christmas charity oh look what you've
started Dylan
look what you started in the chat
gotta be something better on
been hearing good things about this one
pretty sure you can fast travel too but
I don't really want to fast travel
ing the Spiderman's incredible takedown
of rhino subscribe subscribe
podcasts can be enabled or disabled via
VIA audio settings in the options menu
yeah now I'm remembering how to do that
launch Pizza
ooh combat challenges let's go
spread throughout the city each one
focuses on a new move or technique okay
training oh I am so down
first up air combat fighting the enemy
on your turns is a great way to gain
your game I think you hold square yeah
yeah
I actually remembered
and now a personal favorite
uh press X to jump hold square okay with
the right parts but I can make it
portable
I am so glad they included this
I can imagine the people who played this
immediately after beating the first
Spider-Man we're just like why do they
have this in here
but me as somebody it's been years since
I played the first one
whole square or whole triangle okay I
did remember this one
all right yeah this is dope bless Peter
Parker
combine these two moves
Oh okay that's cool
hold square to launch and then you can
yank them back down or hold square and
then you fight them in the air
[Music]
all right let's try this launch
Old Triangle to yank them back down
that's pretty cool L1 square and X
if you have our finisher ready can I use
it
pretty good
I think we just fight these guys now
he doesn't want me to do anything
specific
yeah finish off the hollow guys that's
what it says now
tons of high-tech gear we can sell it oh
crap
there's actually guys here now no way
okay let's go take this
big red detect here gonna make fake some
of this stuff just so you know this is
official Spider-Man Tech
yellow that authorized
dude I don't feel like I used that
yanking them down move much at all in my
first playthrough
oh wait now we've got these guys again
you see them too
ouch
oh wait I have these things too
web shooters and gravity well okay
there's gravity well right there
I can't believe I'm having to fight
these things and uh actual humans at the
same time
[Music]
thieves there we go now to fix a
training Sim
23 days till the Spider-Man 2 trailer
or have they said when they were
officially releasing a trailer I didn't
hear that jester
if I can repair their training Sim
Colonel panic
oh let's try a bios reset
nice that did it
I know they haven't released anything in
a while in combat challenges
gotta check these out when I get a
chance
oh yeah I love these challenges
from the first game
all right challenge unavailable during
mission okay so we're in a mission right
now
all right let's show me how to get to
those
more XP earned
I just walked by and I'm pretty sure
someone's breaking it uh yeah I'll look
into it hey so I want to hear more about
your new spider powers I think it's some
kind of bioelectric discharge or
supercharged static electricity no
I don't have to just sit
maybe that's what the frame rate thing
was
for this suit
they haven't announced a date yet for it
Luna but apparently they're still saying
this year
it's gonna be out
you jump the charts from 136 to 87. like
uh wow okay okay
I'm doing a quick pass before I head
downtown for my citizenship test and
another one for you
what do we have here
it's quiet
and what you're standing next to oh that
guy again
the clearly
bad guy
is new for
new form just one canister of this
revolutionary fuel source is enough to
supply Harlem with Clean safe energy for
the next 500 years
soon we'll be opening reactors
throughout Manhattan and then worldwide
get ready for a planet powered by new
form
rock song
we're here for you
rocks on we're here for that
L2 R2 to web zip through the window uh
Baxter once you have played it
I don't want to say too much until
you've played it
they broke a bunch of stuff if you go
we're looking for something
once you've beaten the game Baxter go to
the channel go to our past live streams
and there's a four hour live stream
four hour live stream where it's like my
full review of Hogwarts Legacy we also
talk about DLC potential
in that one too
yeah Luna it'll I'm pretty sure it's PS5
only
yeah they're not gonna do PS4 again
but yeah it'll eventually come over to
PC I would I would say
wait what got canceled Dylan
was just not quick
oh my goodness look at these guys
all right so we have to Venom punch them
yeah Yankees right Venom's a good name
all right so then we have we have venom
punch ready again
[Music]
dude it's taking a little getting used
to after playing so much Hogwarts Legacy
and hitting that
triangle for protego
oh yeah I can throw that back at them
[Music]
oh heel heel
oh yeah see every time we get hit we
completely lose
any progress we've made
oh my gosh
it took me out quick
we completely lose any progress we made
in that Venom punch meter
the tech is unbelievable
yeah Jackie's right all right I feel
like we need a lot of
dodging here
oh there we go take him out then we got
a Venom punch ready
Memory Metal
oh dude we punched him even when we were
on the side right there
the combat is so fun in this
and I'm liking this new element to Miles
like this Venom stuff
that is totally
not something that's in the main game
unless I just completely forgot about it
I don't think so
[Music]
oh my goodness what is that over there
Dodge
stuff in the reactor it's not installed
yet still talking about shipments
oh man you know what I just remember all
these Reflections in here
I'm pretty sure they have a performance
Ray tracing one too
no heel heel heel heel
all this glass it just got me thinking
it would look absolutely amazing with
Ray tracing right now
not die please do not die
yes
[Music]
see ya sometimes oh throw that back
there we go
no no no don't die
no way
okay these are actually this is actually
tough right here all right let's go to
settings here
oh dude I knew it
I knew it okay performance this is a 60
frames per second mode without graphical
features like Ray tracing enhanced
lighting and additional VFX temporal
techniques provide a 4K picture from a
lower resolution base
this is an alternate version of the 60
frames per second performance mode
adding Ray tracing by adjusting the
scene resolution
reflection quality and pedestrian
density
oh I feel like we should have this one
on
we gotta restart it's okay hey heading
out Dylan have a good one dude
oh yeah look at the floor I can already
tell
but the question is
we'll we'll see how it plays out if we
decide it's a big enough hit to the
resolution like so far I'm not noticing
too much of a difference
take the turn
I've got presents what
it's Christy with a super chat
Christy welcome in thank you so much for
the Super Chat
just popping in to say hello well I'm
glad you did Christy good to see you
glad you're having a good night as I am
getting absolutely wrecked right now
oh come on throw it back
hello
no I want to go over here
and then hit him with the yep yep yep
there we go
yeah go ahead finish him
W game I know I love the first one and I
just never got around to playing Miles
Morales
combat's just so good
all right is that it
finally we got him
all right
I need to figure out what they found so
I know where they're going to hit next
yeah I think I like the performance rage
racing
I feel like it looks just a little bit
better overall and the resolution
doesn't take too big of a hit we'll see
when I get outside if I change my mind
all right we're trying to shipment s but
why
go ninja oh come in
finally able to catch another stream
good to see you here
how's it been going for you go ninja
well that's right we did earn I get home
Christmas dinner sounded pretty good
right about now
we did earn some more that group skill
points
all right let's see if we go back to our
skills
you got the addition with both games
nice yeah I played the first one when it
came out on
PS4
and then got this one day one when I got
my PS5
all right increase the rate yeah I feel
like that's a
that's a good one to have
Old Triangle to perform a Venom yank
attack after sending an enemy flying
wait hold wide why hold triangle to
perform a Vietnam yank attack after
sending an enemy flying
from a melee combo or Venom attack all
right let's watch it up there
ah okay that's all right it's all right
that's level six we can't get that one
yet that's level five level five level
three we could get this one L1 and X
launches nearby enemies into the air
disarming and Venom stunning them okay
that could be pretty useful
I mean we might as well just buy all
this right we've got enough
we have enough so
I just need to remember to try some of
these out
oh wait I didn't see these down here
com I need to complete combat challenge
1.0 when throwing an enemy rapidly press
triangle during oh dude yeah we
definitely need to get that press X on
contact when zipping to a point to
massively boost
Point launch distance yeah I had that in
the regular
regular game traversal challenge 1.0
completed I should try to complete that
you didn't have a chance to play the
first one so I thought it was more
Spider-Man so it's better
um I thought it was more Spider-Man so
it's better I'm not sure what you mean
there
it is it's like the Peter Parker
Spider-Man you play you play through his
hymn in that one
doubles the length of time enemies are
Venom stunned uh yeah for sure
and then we still have one skill plan
available
yeah I think we should try to do this
challenge right here because that's a
really important one to have
but now where do I go to see the
challenges
are we are all of these are already
complete
they just go on the map
you Legend okay here we go traversal
challenges
it's the one that looks like that
I'm already close to this though so I
should probably just
let's complete this first
and then we'll go for that
you heading out Jake have a good one
dude appreciate you stopping by
congrats again on the
on the Lifeguard news
all right into your apartment
oh is this where he's gonna change
[Music]
yeah I like that suit a lot
oh my gosh the detail on the shoes
this game just looks so good even in
performance mode here
Middle School graduation
I haven't seen these two in a while
congrats miles and
what is that Finn
p-h-i-n
you're gonna kick high schools you know
what Rick
I mean it was two games I hadn't played
so it's better oh gotcha yeah yeah yeah
considering you hadn't played both of
them absolutely
oh look at this look at his comics
down there
in the little uh
like a little canvas on the wall there
what do we have over here Pete took me
to see this he totally cried at the end
and so did I
oh dude look at his controllers in here
look at his controllers
wow what system is that you guys
this looks like some kind of uh
third party thing right here
and then the TV
dude
old school TV
man hey GG glad you got to stop by have
a good one
and uh hope you enjoy
enjoy Hogwarts when you finally get to
play it this week this weekend I guess
oh wait wait this one really hasn't sunk
in yet
still feels like abella's apartment not
ours
let's see what genki's working on
oh SP nonagon dude needs to finish so I
can play it
still gotta box up the last of abuela
stuff and ship it to her in Puerto Rico
playing quidditch World Cup Kevin nice
get it cleaned up real quick brushing up
your quidditch skills for uh quitted
Champions huh
I invited a guest tonight
can you get the apartment ready oh
um maybe put on some music set the mood
ah nacha really your campaign manager on
Christmas Eve well tomorrow's rally
isn't going to plan itself thanks for
getting the apartment ready mijo hello
all right oh look at the snow outside
can we turn the tree on
yeah plug that tree up
there you go me too he loves that little
guy hey no Christmas like a Brooklyn
Christmas
I miss hearing them say that
oh so his dad's make you proud dad
okay
no records
hey Mom where's Dad's vinyl
thanks
no
yeah
dude everything just looks so good in
here I guess Mom's not done unpacking
either
the wallpaper just screams Abuela
what's that
must have gotten mixed up in the mouth
one of dad's old case vows Prowler who's
the prowler
I wonder if Dad ever caught the guy oh
there he is
haven't looked through these since
before City Hall
dad's favorite album he put this on
every Sunday while he made coffee
oh do we actually get to pick
okay wait forward let's see what else is
in here
[Music]
all right that's the leader for me right
now
okay forward
I think this was Uncle Aaron's
dad never played it but
he also never got rid of it
I'm gonna do the middle one
salmon and then take
who is 100 of these because the article
mentioned dad
who is the Spider-Man if only you knew
my
look at these boxes man just like all
the little details
tell you man gaming artists they're just
Wizards
you sure bleach is a good idea yeah for
sure why no reason
mom city council run came together fast
people in Harlem really love her
all right so she's running for city
council what's the
one of your favorite games Simeon
I played so I played the first one you
know with with the focus on Peter Parker
but I haven't played this one until now
you are watching it live but yeah I love
I love the first one so good
I expect I will enjoy this as well
you call your Puerto Rican friends
Spidey because miles is Puerto Rican
nice
that doorbell's been broken for years
yeah I'm having trouble remembering so
who is
this guy right here
okay so that's his friend
she just said how are your parents
it's fun having you in the house
it's good to be here miss Morales all
right gotcha
just answer my question perfectly
I don't want to leave this conversation
yet
I'm right here
I'm happy we could cut down on your
commute time
yeah yeah
I'm going
Finn hey fix your doorbell
so good to see you
how are you it's been like months
A lot's changed yeah
so use the one from the picture is that
is that so glad you could make it thanks
for inviting me Miss Morales
we missed you well this one especially
uh awkward Mom this is Genki my friend
from Brooklyn Visions Academy Genki this
is Finn
my best friend my other best friend
oh yeah you guys won the middle school
science fair at County right you made a
uh energy converter jinx
ah the wiring in this right on cue I'll
check the circle
yeah
so Christmas by candlelight I
power back on
we got this
no good breaker doesn't have power looks
like
let me check if I can see anything from
the fire escape okay honey I don't like
this
I don't like it
the Transformer from here
scan for Clues
people on the roof can't go up there
okay wait so am I just supposed to look
and see me up here probably follow this
hope no one can see you
I hope so
um
Christmas dinner
can't save Christmas dinner
it would
man those lights are bright and not
think this through gotta get back inside
ASAP
return to the apartment wait was it that
way
bases are so realistic yet look fake
sometimes they can't get certain things
that yeah I know it's games are getting
so close though
especially games like I don't know if
you've seen uh like The Last of Us Part
two man it's just
Yankee okay so he knows
you know Precious Moments you gotta
capture them shouldn't we wait for Miles
no he hates photos what do you do what
are you doing oh he's just trying to get
to the other side
who's ready to eat
you guys sit down I got this smells good
what a nice little Christmas Christmas
dinner we've got going here
something tells me it's all gonna get
ruined though
I don't know what
Finn tell us everything you've been up
to you still in robotics Club
I had to quit but I've been studying
biotech on my own nerd
the guy who has to wear an ascot to
school only on Tuesdays
does your brother Rick still work for
Roxanne
I don't know how anyone could work there
after seeing your last campaign ad you
went for Simon Krieger's jugular that
reminds me
Genki you have a certain Flair for
social media could you spread the word
about tomorrow's rally yeah we'll be
trending by midnight
sometimes it feels like Simon Krieger is
my real opponent
Roxanne has so much influence here that
they don't answer to anyone except their
shareholders
Harlem needs someone to fight for the
community
that's mom's campaign speech voice in
case you couldn't tell
do not hit send
okay okay maybe they got to enjoy a nice
dinner
so what's going on with you what do you
mean you seem
I don't know
distracted
you want to talk about it
not tonight
it's Christmas
hey how are you handling the move from
Brooklyn I mean
it's fine
you hate it no that's your I hate it but
I'm too nice to say it boys no it's
I don't know anybody here and I'm always
having to ask for directions you need to
find a good restaurant a barber shop
somewhere you can shoot hoops
you'll settle in
what if we hang out tomorrow
Just the Two of Us you're not too busy
it's a winter break
I can put off homework for at least
another week
okay
I'll text you it's a date
I mean not a date you know a friend date
[Music]
time I saw you
want miles in the MCU ASAP I mean
are they planning it it's Gotta happen
right
an app custom OS nothing I've ever seen
before but I ran it through a
disassembler so I could reverse engineer
the plug-in architecture and
he's out
going for the Platinum possibly can you
possibly we'll have to see
I just have such a long backlog
right now
it's almost done compiling
oh thank you
ready to try out my app yeah man let's
do this
I'm connected to your Analytics
Let's test drive this baby
all right
sign in
please don't make me actually sign in oh
my gosh first person Spider-Man
swipe left
to access the friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man app it's a friendly
neighborhood
oh this is cool
look someone just made a request
someone just made a request select
Harlem trains out of service from the
activities tab
okay
Aaron Davis
wait what that's my uncle
gotta be a coincidence
I'm headed to the subway stop
all right if they go the same as it is
in into the spider-verse
which I think they are I'm pretty sure I
know who this guy ends up being
what is going on
uh Hey there you needed some help
I'm Spider-Man by the way yeah I know
Aaron Davis
I think somebody's messing with the
sensors I'm getting bad data from the
main relay up top of Grand Central
on my way wait wait
yeah
where's the other Spider-Man oh dang
he's on vacation but don't worry I got
this
I feel like you got to disguise your
voice more than that
I'm hanging around my stop this morning
we'll be Underground
you know anything else about them they
think of themselves as a young monster
wow
tinkerer
thanks for the tip
so uh you got Spider-Man often like for
help
we really have a way to get in touch to
this afternoon but I saw you on the news
last night taking down Ron figured you
were the right person to call cool
have you uh
been working at the subway low nah took
the job last year brother
well anyway boys change your way yeah
yeah
surely the suit's capable of that
my watch doesn't exactly paint
well
when we fix them you can tell your boss
you showed initiative by using the
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man app
all right we still I forgot to do the uh
the other thing
so we can unlock those other
upgrades
yeah especially your uncle too
like your uncle will definitely
recognize your your voice
all right wait no don't go over there
there are way too many wires on this one
it's got to be messing with the signal
where do these cables go
let's see over here
oh inside
yo
when enemies are suspicious the question
mark icon will appear and they will
investigate
if you see the exclamation point icon
you've been spotted uh yeah I think I'm
hey
I think I've been spotted
you all right dude
this is crazy Tech
to do this but
senses are back online what did you do
took care of the guy messing with it and
it looks like they left some of their
toys behind they tried it in homecoming
didn't work ah
hey I'm gonna have to call you back
oh what's he found
whoa
I'm trying to remember that part Luna I
can't remember it right now
underground caches contain Tech parts
that can be used to craft suits suit
mods visor mods and Gadget upgrades
open the gadget menu okay hold X on the
hollow drone Gadget to craft there's so
many little
wait hold X on on this
on the hollow drone Gadget where is that
at
oh right here this one hollow drone
unlock new gadgets and Gadget upgrades
with activity tokens and Tech Parts earn
activity tokens and Tech Parts by
completing city-wide activities this
Tech has a pretty unique RF
I wonder if I can track it all right so
there are so many of these there's a
bunch more of these around the city yeah
so many of these that we can go out and
do
underground caches oh wow
all right so when you complete those you
get Tech Parts which is not
related to this
it's related to
the skill no not skills
uh something with the suit I just saw it
you can do something with a suit once
you get those I think that's what it
said anyway
all right so let's go ahead and I want
to mark all right well let's go get out
of here right now as soon as we complete
this we'll mark it perfect time to try
out if we don't forget
okay
oh that's pretty cool we can use those
guys now
[Music]
oh I didn't mean to put another one out
I forgot
okay so that's just the regular web
shooters
that's what I was trying to shoot that
time
[Music]
there we go I was thinking man I gotta
be close to a finisher
[Music]
dude the graphical effects when you do
that Venom strike are incredible
when he hunted down Aaron Davis
you try to do a voice changer Aaron was
like I know what a little girl said oh
uh
I forgot about that
something must have gone down at the
yard it was the underground messing with
your sensors
thinking does roxon ever use a Subway to
ship new form Roxanne uh the subway
system was designed to carry people not
free this line got some updates when
roxon Plaza so they could be using it
under the table
I follow up on it
so uh you mentioned your brother you got
another family I haven't seen them
into mixed beats together well maybe now
you can see him again then there we go
yeah
I should go right underground bye
speaking of uh
into the spider-verse though we don't
have much longer to go until
into the spider-verse 2 comes out
I think it's what early June I believe
underground's wrecking everything
maybe I can stop them quietly
stop them quietly okay press R3 to show
enemies that are safe to take Downs
shoot webs at surfaces and objects to
lure enemies
okay
all right and then is he far enough away
he is
perch takedown
I feel like he would hear that
was my triangle for a web strike nice
then zip out of sight there we go
good time to try out Pete's visor Tech
old L2 and hover over an enemy to tag
nice
oh this is crazy
shoot webs at the ground or distraction
oh yeah yeah I know about that
can we do oh you can do it through a
wall too
all right anybody else we need to track
oh man okay so let's see if we could do
all of this oh there's another guy right
there
this guy might actually be
okay yeah he's safe perch take down
oh he's got Danger on him
see I love this kind of Self in games
man this is so fun
that should turn safe here in a second
right
there we go
time
but why is he a danger
geez get back up
I did not
wait why does he keep it there there
must be another one close to that guy
that
kept flashing danger occasionally oh
wait wait wait
okay yeah we were not tracking that guy
didn't even see me
okay now you are safe perfect
come on
what I didn't even know about that Luna
I'm not I'm not even familiar with that
with that character
okay wait what is
hello that one still says danger
all right all right so we need to let's
shoot
we need to get you away
I'm sure I heard something
oh there we go there we go there we go
everybody look around
no that's not what I meant to do
I meant to just shoot the web
well actually you might be safe yeah
you know get back up get back up get
back up
that's it right I think that's the last
one
oh there is another guy
that's it right is that it time bro
that's all of them there we go the
Train's back on the tracks controls are
probably in the office
trolls are probably in the office over
here okay
tinkerer
long said that's their leader
tinkerer you've read the controls
gonna have to get the trains back on the
tracks by hand you see her fighting
while pregnant oh like in the trailer
turntable
all right if you need help with a puzzle
you can trigger a hint for more
information press R3 to show puzzle
hints
okay I don't even know
what did he say I can use that oh
probably this thing over here it's been
the turntable find a way to line up
three trains in front of the access
tunnel
line up three trains
in front of the access tunnel dude were
there puzzles in the main game I should
move the train that's already on the
turntable
then I can worry about the others
okay is there
there's something we do to turn this
all right it's it's like highlighting
these little
there we go okay
dad never talked about what happened
that works all right so
all right we don't have anything right
now
so this will be the first one I guess
what
that doesn't look right
oh we need three though right
oh wait we need all three of them to be
on here huh
I don't know where we're supposed to
line them up
come on webs move the train yeah yeah
okay that's what I was gonna do
oh maybe we need them all over here
this way
let's see I'll pull this one over here
and see if he says that's correct
if he does then we just have to pull the
other one
good all right perfect
okay so we probably want to leave that
one some new form shipments then kills
leave that one off right now though
don't try to stop new form from reaching
the city or
all right is there a way to get this out
of the way oh there's another one back
here
okay the question is can we get this one
I don't see anything to uh
line up three train cars okay I see
these two
those two will be no problem but where
oh oh wait a second can we use this
somehow
this is what I was thinking at first
that we're gonna have to like lift one
all right I don't know why this is is
lighting up over here don't tell me guys
don't tell me
I'll get it it might take me a second
but I'll get it here
okay is there another one back here that
we can't see
line up three train cars in front of the
tunnel
all right oh I see it I see it I see it
I see it
oh we better move out of the way quickly
there we go
all right now the question is
how do we knock it down
right there
rapidly tapped R1 to lock a gear in
place
oh up there okay
we've got trains on the tracks
nice
we got it we got it
hey our radiant gaming what is up
welcome in welcome in love Spider-Man
PS4 haven't had a chance to play Miles
Morales dude we're pretty early they
busted the controls here too but it is
definitely as good so far with a few a
few new twists even in terms of gameplay
actually this right here this Venom
charge that we're about to use
see is that gonna work
who's that to power the trains
probably my webs are conductive and you
can actually use that in battle too
all right use R to look at the generator
okay wait hold L2 to aim at the
generator and press R1 to fire a tether
web
this is new
I don't even remember many puzzles in
the first game
yeah yeah we're playing on PS5 yep
oh yeah the haptic feedback with the
webs did anything change when you're in
vandal's just lit up like Christmas
good job kid glad to help
if anything else comes up just post a
note in the app wait a second
I got a little something here oh I
thought he was gonna say I think I know
you for me this
I can do
cool cool
it back now
all right
sounds good
uh what have you guys been up to our
radiant you guys having uh having a good
week so far
and Rossi welcome in welcome back Rossi
see I don't okay I know I want to hear
what he has to say
but I keep putting this off I'm gonna
forget
I want to mark this right now
any of these traversal challenges I
really don't care which one yeah I'm
gonna mark this one over here and dude
look at all these underground caches
I mean let's just Mark that one
it's along the way
[Music]
sure man oh and thanks for the gift it
is awesome
okay MJ needs me gotta go bye
busy working on some uh oh weddings
before tears of the kingdom yes
exactly did I just go past it I I
totally did
this from Tails
oh I should definitely check that out
now that the whole City's counting on me
we're like the number one app in NYC
right now check it out as soon as you're
done with your uncle
still doesn't know you're you right I've
had a couple of near misses in here
maybe
I'll check the app as soon as I'm done
later
yeah I can't believe tears of the
Kingdom leaked how did that have have
you followed that story very much
I'd love to know how that happens
okay so Tech Parts all right what do we
do with those Tech Parts man I know they
literally just told me
yes here it is it was I think it was on
the suits
I think it was with the the mods or
whatever okay visor mod
hold on let me read this uh visor mods
augment Spider-Man's Vision to provide
more information and then you have the
suit mods suit mods upgrade Spider-Man
suit to optimize it for different
situations
uh Vibe the verse use this mod to LEAP
into the spider-verse and cause the
attached suit to mimic the aesthetic of
a different Earth yes this is what I was
talking about okay I am all about high
frame rates and games but if you guys
haven't seen this
this is actually pretty crazy if you've
okay so the the game is still running at
60fps but dude look at how he moves now
it makes it look like you were watching
the movie
it is so trippy
I don't even know what frame rate it's
running at but it's just like
Mike welcome in Mike and yes Rossi we we
have indeed played uh Fallen order
haven't played the new one yet but I
have played Fallen order
we actually have a full playthrough of
that over on our let's play Channel if
you guys are interested so I would never
I don't
I don't play through the game like this
but it's just such a cool little feature
to play around with
like even if you even when you're in
combat
look at that man
oh it's so crazy
all right so that was in the suit mod so
I need to turn that back off
all right so how much do we need
we need that okay so we have one of
those little gear things right now
oh wow so for these you need activity
tokens that one was just free we just
got that automatically see if we have
enough for any of these visor mods
oh we do we already have this actually
these are these are free they're already
included use this mod to peer into the
spider-verse and visualize combat sound
effects no way so you could do it with
the combat too
visualize combat sound effects oh that's
crazy man
I want to know what it means by combat
sound effects
visualize combat sound effects
we're gonna leave that on for a second
I'm gonna leave that on just to see all
right let's go ahead and grab this other
one over here
I know I think it looks pretty cool to
try it out
oh where'd it go
I don't like how it disappears when you
get closer
oh wait wait wait
we're closer we're closer
there it is
oh goodness who are you
oh there you go
it's like the old school Batman I love
it
oh goodness relax
will kill you
I can't remember if Spider-Man ever had
a show where they did the little effects
like that but the old school Batman TV
show Absolutely did
gotta be the last one
that is so funny
all right so let's go ahead and turn
that back off
and let's see if we have enough to uh I
want to see what this uh this one is
probably more worth our while decreased
damage uh from range attacks by 25 yeah
for sure
oh yeah I think so I I think I'm
definitely going to be playing tears of
the Kingdom at launch
yeah don't know if I'll be streaming it
here or on YouTube though we've kind of
been experimenting with both see how uh
see where our best fit is streaming wise
all right so that one only costs one
increases the range of Venom punch
Splash damage which allows more enemies
to be stunned yeah I feel like that's
worthwhile
I want to save does that just cost one
oh it doesn't tell me does it
doesn't tell me because it's locked all
right I'm not going to buy anything yet
because
all these caches I want to go do this
right here
because I really want to get that
upgrade for the point launch
yeah I'm thinking I might hold off on
Jedi Survivor
I know the PS5 version doesn't run too
bad but I think I might wait a little
bit until they
have patched it a little bit more
just been hearing horror stories
my Fallen order seven minutes guide hey
nice I appreciate it
thank you for letting me know
I uh I'm still shocked that that video
didn't do
do better
it's got like not many views
and I thought that was going to be I was
like oh this is gonna be I put it's
crazy because it's only a little over
seven minutes long
but man that video took so long to do to
get all the footage and everything
yeah maybe it's one of those that over
time it'll get get more people checking
it out
but I'm glad at least somebody found it
helpful
okay wait hold on can I not
no can I not access this while I'm in a
mission
uh oh my gosh challenge unavailable
during a mission I thought we completed
the mission
you gotta be kidding me
yeah at first a little behind the scenes
story for you on that video I was
originally gonna try to do it in five
minutes
and I watched like
I just beaten the game so the game was
fresh in my mind back when I finish
helping up I watched like five other
Jedi Fallen order videos I'm almost
there you gotta hurry Spiderman
underground wrote my script
and then I was like there's no way this
is going to be five days can't hang
tight and don't go outside
in fact in my original script I was like
everything in five minutes or less
and so then I recorded it and it was
like over it was like eight nine minutes
long I was like okay I don't think I can
get it under five minutes
but I think I can get it under seven
minutes
so that's what we went with
oh no
all right who's got the guns let's get
them out of their hands
cheap knockoff
oh no
oh no we're not gonna allow that
see what was the uh in Air Attack
jumping and then Square that's right
foreign
stop shooting
there we go get a little finisher then
we've got the Venom strike ready
dude that Venom strike is awesome
never Bombs all right is that it time
remaining what
hold on what am I supposed to do
oh yeah yeah I remember this I remember
this
from the main game
It's All Coming Back to Me
it's funny hearing about the bugs for
Survivor oh you do you you got a PS5 now
though right
Oh wait we're leaving the mission area
it's over here
yeah see I was playing Fallen order
oh there it is
I played Fallen order so long after it
first came out that every and on a PS5
so everything ran beautifully for me
but I heard some people said that it it
had some problems at launched too
oh no get away from that
we only have 17 seconds I don't like it
here we go
across the intersection another one on
it you're making a game Luna what
what kind of game is it
I'm so in I'm intrigued
yeah I had two two seconds to spare
[Music]
oh that's actually it I thought I had to
defeat all the enemies first
actually I don't know if I'm gonna have
enough time to defeat the enemies
we got 28 seconds
where's it at where's it at
there it is
watch out cops
you gotta take care of this
why does it stop no forms
oh wait I've got dude I wish there was a
some sort of more obvious on-screen
indicator when I have a Venom strike
ready although at the same time I do
kind of prefer the minimal HUD I like
that there's not
too much on the hood
all right is that it could we clear them
out
no problem Aaron we gotcha
multiplayer build your own superhero
play as a hero against other people's
hero take a while I'm sure
that's crazy that's awesome though are
you like going it alone or do you have a
team do you have people you're working
with
all right so we completed Harlem trains
out of service Spider-Man fixed the
Subways he's doing good work
oh this is like the little app review
dude this app man what a great idea do a
patch job
what's wrong with the suit here you can
see all the resources you've collected
use the resources you've gained to craft
a new mod by selecting it and holding X
okay
or we can craft one of these
we have enough now for the ACT with the
activity tokens all right so decreases
damage oh yeah I feel like that's an
obvious one but for melee attacks
generates a small amount of Health per
hit
okay wait on Venom stun enemies
attacks after a perfect Dodge do 50 more
damage for five seconds
[Music]
I mean if you don't get hit a lot like
if you're better at the game then you
probably won't need that one at all
I'm gonna go with this one first though
since we're still early
a trophy unlock too mod the suit
hey thank you for stopping by
our radiant gaming good to see you
makes you want to play Spider-Man again
dude I've had this game in my backlog
for so long and
when when Jedi Survivor launched in kind
of a not so great state I just I was
like now is the time Now's the Time It's
a shorter game I need to make it happen
I appreciate you stopping by
you're working on it by yourself right
now until you have the right friends the
right amount of money will be by myself
but you're over for help gotcha I mean
hey there have been some incredible
games made by just one person it's
actually amazing what
what people can do I'm sure if you
stick with it and you know
learn learn as you go
you'd be able to do it something about
this one I don't really like I don't
know it's just too
it's too robotic feeling for me the
colors are great
this one is pretty good
tracksuit I like that one quite a bit
the great responsibility suit nah not
feeling that one at all I mean so far
this one is Far and Away the best one
let's see does it actually show you the
other ones nah you just you can see a
little bit of them
time to Rally okay I feel like that's
the main one for this game
all right so let's see did we unlock
anything else
uh that's the spider-verse one okay
let's check out the gadgets
this is still locked right here
oh what do we have here increases uh Max
websheet or ammo capacity by two
and then the hollow drone
all right but we don't have enough for
any of these yet you okay Mr Davis
oh hey here you go
one year unlimited subway pass thanks
did I get the name right
how did you oh he did know dude
he did know
I kind of suspected when I saw the news
yesterday
watching your move
you're moving guys left and right
could have sworn I was back at the park
playing pickup with you and your dad
you were quick then
a lot quicker now well that didn't take
long guys don't worry
tell your mom
promise
look at you if your dad can see you now
he probably freaked out
he'd definitely freak out so you taking
over for the other Spider-Man nah like I
said he's just on vacation right and he
left you in charge
yeah
a lot of responsibility for kids your
age
I can handle it
hope so but listen you get in over your
head you give me a call
I'm here for you
um
thanks hunk
okay well that's already setting it up
very differently than how it plays out
and into the spider-verse
very very different
he definitely needs a Spiderman
Patrol for a while swipe left
oh this is so cool
so this is how you manage your missions
this is awesome I like this a lot and
then you have your crimes right here
like when people can report crimes oh
that is too cool
so do you have to do that or can you
also just find it randomly I wonder as
you go
I'm not even gonna Mark any of those
though because I
want to get this one first
this one that I've been talking about
basically the whole time
I wanted to tell you my favorite food
truck will be at the rally tonight look
out for a logo with a giant hero okay
thanks for the tip
we haven't started a mission
you forgot to text Finn
oh no
dude you better text her back
at the subway stop by our house did you
know he's working there no
I don't want you around here oh
you and dad never told me why I wasn't
allowed to see him anymore
he used to come by her place all the
time
that's for Aaron to explain
give me one second
sorry honey we're still setting up it's
all good go save the world mom one boat
at a time have I ever told you you're my
favorite son I've got Steve competition
I love you bye crime in progress It's
close by sorry
I have to do this
I absolutely have to do this
I love these little challenges
all checkpoints four time Runs Out
well I'm ready for this let's Boogie
wait where do we start
practice
oh I missed one
come on
oh goodness gracious
oh this is bad
oh we missed that one
okay ultimate it says
no
sorry it's all right I knew we weren't
gonna get it first try
okay
that actually wasn't that wasn't bad 38
seconds
so you don't actually have to hit all of
them
hey have a good one Luna thank you for
being here
I want to retry
foreign
okay
follow the path okay
okay gotcha gotcha gotcha
so it doesn't really matter I don't have
to hit exactly on these spots
that's good to know
oh let's go
all right third time's a charm oh there
you go meet Finn miles we still meeting
today never got a text back from you oh
yeah sorry I've been wrapped up in my
own stuff
but I'm free now where sweet 78th and
West End he forgot but she didn't by the
science center why there
don't be late all right hold on
end
guess I'll find out what she means
better hustle over
Finn Finn 30 seconds literally I promise
I promise 30 seconds 30 seconds
that right there
I feel like I'm wasting a little bit of
time
oh no come on
no
I did not miss that checkpoint
restart challenge
okay Finn
maybe like five minutes five minutes I
promise
are you serious
I was hoping it would count going over
the top like that but it did not
foreign
can I hit that corner
no way dude
why is this getting harder
moves this way
ah wasted a little time right there but
dude no way
way all right so we've got to get on
that the side of that building
so we can perfectly hit that
Giants
come on
oh no
this is like you're the broom house
oh man
it's only because I'm going for the gold
if I would just
nah
I'm just trying to spam it instead of
just actually aiming
all right
oh that was big
swing
baby firstly sounds kind of dope
no
wasting time
32. oh my gosh
we need in 30 seconds for the for the
ultimate guys for the gold up there
I'm gonna crack up if Finn like actually
leaves like if you lose that mission
okay I wanted to test that out to see
if it would count it being that high
above it it does not
learning
moves
boom right there
yes
boom that's gotta be it 30 on the dots
let's go
oh man all right
finally now
now if I'm right we can go into skills
oh you don't even have to do we not even
have to buy that oh we don't let's go
it's automatic when you complete the
challenge
I am really early uh how do you say that
name Emma V IM of I I'm still pretty
early I'm uh I just got the part where I
need to go meet Finn so
did the mission with the uncle
now we're going to meet up with Finn
right now but we're still very very
early
oh and then we got a complete
oh dude okay all right well I'm glad to
know that we we unlocked that
this one right here Venom stun enemies
knocked into other yeah let's go ahead
and buy that
take 50 yep let's just buy all these
we've got enough
okay now hopefully Finn's not gonna be
too mad at us
spin faster welcome in nice to be able
to catch a stream
[Music]
I am glad you're here my friend glad
you're here
on the back of someone else's newspaper
or your friends play-by-play oh wow has
it been that long spin no way
we've been streaming a lot over on
Twitch as well
so if you played the game Spin if you
played a Star Wars or Star Wars have you
played Hogwarts are you uh on last
genology
[Applause]
hey molasses up here
fire escapes shakier she just called me
molasses
welcome back Christy
got one playthrough nice glad you
enjoyed it spin yeah I had a great time
still
this is why you wanted to meet here
almost bailed you took so long
give me a hand it's stuck don't you guys
need some gloves on
time capsules seem better days
you remember the combination
yeah it's uh
man it's uh
flashback I gotta start remembering this
code not always going to be around to
tell you well remember we'll remember
we'll remember yeah yeah good now uh
what are you gonna put inside this bad
boy secret Time Capsule only miles and I
know
oh that's right keep it secret keep it
safe hey Rick you're gonna take that job
at Roxanne or what why you're gonna take
it if I don't maybe waiting to see the
offer okay competition eh well they're
talking a good game want me to he's her
brother right
you know me clean power save the world
I love my nerdy fan club oh speak of the
devil rock song back in a sec
code right
the Fibonacci sequence nice
reward
I mean our energy converter yeah her
last name's Mason here we go
you think it's still on display at the
Science Center
hope so
wow look at this
goober Central
rig lick and Suave as ever though yeah
something going on with him
you guys fight or something no
no fight
Finn it's fine
why do we really lose touch
miles asking the real questions I gotta
go oh she she dodging them no
feel like we both have stuff for not
sharing next time we hang no secrets
okay yeah
Maybe
if you're on time
see you soon short stuff
you know I'm taller than you now right
not in here
oh
yes Ben they're really good and they are
both of them are on PC now as well yes
Midtown High
but I got into Brooklyn visions
said we stay in touch but
man
High School's like a whole new world
ozcorp Science Center award
gotcha
man it was so good to see Finn
I should find other time capsules we hid
oh a little later dude all the moms
rally these Collectibles man
so many collectibles
oh dude that's such a cool way to do the
Fast Travel
he gave us that
the uh subway pass
all right I guess we have to go here I
think yeah we do
and spin I'm actually I'm on PS5 and I'm
playing on the performance mode so
you're playing on if you have a good
powerful PC it would look even better
probably check
you got the house
key yeah I'm in the performance Ray
tracing mode
and it has felt very sweet
yeah the combat's really good
it's gonna be fine
you think the combat is different than
remastered
man it's been a while since I played the
first one so awesome
yeah this is pretty cool he definitely
has some new elements like the Venom
punch and all that
mom is a politician
skill sets right oh it's growling people
educating them making sure they don't
throw things at each other
that looks really cool
you're welcome
oh
sorry
I should take ASL with you next semester
I basically already mastered espanol
man I used to know a lot of sign
language
when I was in grade school we had
there was someone deaf in our class and
he was also on our basketball team
and so a lot of us learn learn some sign
language through him
I used to be able to do the whole uh
Pledge of Allegiance
in sign language
and the Star-Spangled Banner that's
right we did we used to do both of them
Gloria
I'm speaking of no shoes for you till
after winter break
open by then what do you mean
don't worry about it enjoy your mom's
speech I'll call you after break
yeah consoles have come a long way
I mean I still
I still prefer uh console actually I
went to PC for a while
just kept having too many problems
and nowadays I mean it's like
yeah
they're just not able to optimize for
all these different systems
oh hey isn't this our uncle it is good
to see you here
a queer out before your mom sees me
who's this
you look out for my nephews you here
I'll try but he doesn't make it easy I'm
standing right here
enjoy your mom's speech
dude yeah I have no idea what happened
with uh
redfall I was watching as people play it
last night and man it looks rough
but dude I love this song I love both
Dishonored games
they're gonna make a follow-up to this
or the first Spider-Man game Kevin so
Spider-Man 2 they've said is coming out
this year
but that's actually a good question I it
may have both of them in there
like Peter Parker and miles
although I can't say much because I
don't know how this I don't know how
this one leaves it off it's my first
time playing it for real
what we lost
when rock song bulldozed this block hey
are you okay let me remind you yeah it's
just last time you get one of these my
bad
daycare you'll be okay
your mom's got people looking out for
her
now your spiders
it's experimental fuel across the city
but they won't tell us the risk
this message mysterious
I was like yeah we saw this guy
wait why are they attacking
because she was talking against
roxon or whatever right so why are they
attacking her rally
I guess because they're there
dude the combat's so good
where are you up there
Dodge
all right I feel like I'm getting
targeted from another yeah we are I see
him
oh where'd that guy all these guys
don't worry we're taking care of her
what about you what's the underground
doing oh yikes dude I'm not playing on
the hardest difficulty but man when you
get hit
takes down a lot of Health
thanks for helping my mom
gonna stop you and your glow stick guns
oh
yeah
oh he just got stuck right there
Arkham City yeah I feel like Arkham City
is the one that kind of started off the
what was that just like this fluid
combat that works so well in these types
of games
and honestly you could even see a little
bit of that inspiration with Hogwarts
Legacy I feel like obviously it has to
be ranged but
[Music]
no stay where it's safe what's your hurt
what if something happens to you while
I'm not there this isn't like City Hall
we're all okay
I'll be back soon
Bridge there was an explosion all right
but if roxon shows up run you got it
they'll look for some of the blame for
all this and it won't just be the
tinkerer okay the tinkerer that's right
that's his name
I knew we had seen that somewhere
hurry
looks like the plaza was just a warm-up
or distraction
hey spin remember they are insomniacs
working on uh Wolverine
which should be
incredible I can't wait to see how they
handle Wolverine
ignore everything else
oh dude I think I know who that is
I think I know who's behind that mask
and grab as much as you can carry
[Music]
oh I knew it dude
I didn't think we were gonna get the
reveal that quick though
oh I knew it
she got mad awkward when we were talking
about no more secrets
huh and then something about in that cut
scene The Voice just sounded too much
like her right there gave it away a
little bit
I saw the explosions spin
today
this is not your fault man I was so
happy to see her if you put everything
together
sorry I didn't put it together until
right before she revealed herself anyway
unintendedly though she did not do that
on purpose
[Music]
whoa lots of guns lots of guns
slide under
oh my gosh with that upgrade
got so many of them in there
oh dude we have two slots now I forgot
about that
Oh I thought they were closer or I
thought
I thought that was gonna hit further
away than it did
yeah it's been they're working on a
Spider-Man game now which they've
they've shown basically nothing except
I think there's like one
teaser art
finisher ready
all right there we go
[Music]
foreign
what is it about Spider-Man and the
bridges man
what is it about the bridges
oh and the bus that's right you gotta
have the bus
Spider-Man Bridges and buses
Tale As Old As Time
people are okay what do we do
all right put out the fire okay
wait what am I supposed to do R1
Aussie welcome in
hold on I gotta watch the button prompts
right here
thank you man
people they're trash
got an idea
oh I think I see where he's going with
this
[Music]
need something they can cross
okay over here
there we go there we go
look at the biceps
look at him flexing
she would have been all right it was
just water
right
but yeah Aussie uh I played the first
one
but I haven't played Miles Morales the
follow-up
so this is our first playthrough of it
hanging by a thread
I did this
I'm powers
I made it explode
oh no now what
oh this is what is uncle
that's what his uncle warned him about
copy
no
no I'm not your enemy what are you doing
saved us
with that phone away now I
don't know right now
this is your last warning I saved him
foreign
oh that's right he's getting that
the invisible power
he's like dude
what happened to rock song being here
for us
they were gonna shoot me so you didn't
know about that power did he listen
he's not acting very surprised though
I don't know genuinely worried about
Starfield
yeah I mean we'll see
usually I mean
usually that team delivers but
we shall see
hey JP what's up
bioelectricity nah nah she would have
been fine
should have been fine
I'm kidding I'm kidding
Finn's the tinkerer
she stole the new form
no idea why
it's my fault the bridge blew up no it's
not
I'm headed to the campaign headquarters
you boys need anything while I'm out
I could pick up Coco
I thought you'd quit after last night
why would I quit
I said I'd fight for my home
I meant it
you could have
you could have died
our family doesn't give up
you know that
mom
Felicity that Coco would be great
if you don't mind
I don't mind
when I got powers
and I I thought I would be able to fix
anything
do anything that Spider-Man does
whenever you say Spider-Man you always
always you're Spider-Man
you can fix this
your way
yeah the soundtrack's great hopefully it
doesn't get
flagged on uh
the YouTube
copy
r-i-g-h-t I don't even want to say it
[Music]
new suit unlocked the classic suit let's
go
things are big time now huh feels like
people need friendly neighborhood now
more than ever we've got to think of a
shorter name
all the good apps are one word
the good answer one word
I feel like that is pretty true
a bridge exploded or a bagel was
fumigated which doesn't make any sense
in context either way I'm looking at
flights I can be back tomorrow night no
don't do that it's okay I figured out
who's responding to do that and I'm
gonna stop them I promise okay oh this
suit is slick man
I'm in progress all right okay let's
tackle one of these
by the way to anyone on the replay Squad
if you guys notice any sort of weird
cuts or edits
we were just talking about how awesome
the music in this music is in this game
I hope that we're good with copyright
but if we're not you'll probably see
some weird cuts where I have to go in
and YouTube can clip it out but it'll
just look like these weird little uh
wait where's the crime
oh wait where is it
defeat the criminals I don't see any
criminals oh wait are they up here
oh dude they're up on top of this
building
it's not okay
dude did I just
I didn't punch a civilian did I
can't take all of us
I just saw a challenge that said
something about web throwing a civilian
but
my heart
see everybody wanted to laugh
oh wait web throw three objects at
enemies
oh come on
everybody wanted to laugh at all in
Hogwarts Legacy you basically
just take out so many Wizards I mean
let's be real you do the same thing in
all these superhero games
we just launched that dude off the side
of the building
even though we know that
Peter and miles would not really do that
are you okay you're good nice nice nice
all right so I think we also
dude people always what's the plan Fizz
family
she used to do all of her work can I
just explore for a bit if I'm lucky she
still does wouldn't it be easier
I don't think so man
seeing her on the bridge
she doesn't know that figure out why
she's doing something about us yet man
do what you feel is right
keep me posted at least I don't think
maybe she already figured it out
oh yeah is that is that confirmed is
there is it actually confirmed there's
going to be a May state of play for
Spider-Man
all right so we've got we can just pull
up the map like this
and we can pick the missions that way
but then we can also do this like swipe
on the touchpad
so we have activities and we have crimes
so do these just match up let's look for
one that's close this one right here
Beast is running a toy drive
I bet they need all the help they can
right now
social news Collective
but yeah they have said so little about
the next game
it's kind of crazy how little they've
said about it
no
crime in progress what
oh fine
fine I'll go stop the crime in progress
dude how did he know I was gonna be
right there
oh my gosh those Rockets
that's right you can send them back too
finisher
oh that's a good point Jenny too about
about actors and stuff
because they did have some top-notch
talent for this game
oh so I wonder if you can repeat these
surely you can right because
the bonus objectives I needed to air
launch for enemy swing kick five enemies
I didn't even see it pop up though
during the the mission
oh wait this was just a this was just
this wasn't even the one we were going
to this was a crime in progress
wait what was that press l1x to Venom
jump
oh that was crazy
all right we might as well look for
these caches too when we're
close to one
and are we getting closer yep
but we can't be that lucky every time
what if this account had happened a few
days later during the so-called Storm of
the Century 4 out of 35.
all right so can I do that l1x anytime
I guess you have to uh
yes you have to actually have the meter
I heard you've been having some quiet
Jameson Facebook
we got work to do last inventory check
we had a couple hundred missing you
think somebody stole them
trucks out making pickups but our GPS
transponders have a good one Baxter
thank you for being here
sounds like you got yourself a poser
how am I going to know which one it is
and check their license plates we'll
know which one shouldn't be out there
you can count on me then
gotcha
Yankee how's it going Taylor
yes yes for sure
could use the camera it was uh license
plate numbers I'll let them finish
talking here
hold L2 to aim at the license plate on
the truck
wait what truck
what truck
I don't see a truck
I mean
I don't see a truck you guys
it's not letting me walk around
oh my gosh I'm missing I'm missing
something so obvious aren't I
I I can't move
he's like way over here
way down there no way right
am I glitched
okay hold on let's pause it but yeah
Taylor I uh I played the first one like
right when it came out
and then I don't know somehow never
played this one and I started it right
when I first got my PS5 and then started
playing Demon Souls so
okay wait is it this one that's about to
go by
Feast truck in front of you this one
right
it won't let me walk around though
aim at the license plate on the truck
that's what I thought but I can't move
does he have the license plates
somewhere else
oh my gosh you guys what is going on
I think I think it's glitched or
something
I think you're but yeah like what I
shouldn't I be able to walk around to
the back okay let's do restart last
checkpoint
foreign
that's fine
activity available
which one were we doing
it was one that was really close to me
oh no which one was it
it was
wasn't looters
I don't think it was lost cat
oh you think it was the one passing
which one was it you guys
somebody go back and re rewind the
stream really quick and tell me
which mission was it
oh we're literally standing here
we're in the spot though
today
if you were hurt in the underground's
attack on rocks on lost cat physically
can't find my pigeons it was the toy one
it was something about the toy switching
topics I'm pulling together an expose on
the Underground and I need your help and
now it's just gone any information you
can share it could help us China you
think it was the one that was passing by
it until next time stay safe I thought I
tried to ski in the ones passing by
[Applause]
dude it's gone like I can't get it now
maybe it'll come back I'm gonna go and
just do this next Story Mission
oh activity and new activity available
maybe that's it
my truck stuck this one yes yes
no
that wasn't it either but it was that it
was it was something to do with the
feast truck
I thought it was something about toys
though
yeah it's gone no
maybe it'll come back
that was so weird I just couldn't move
and then I I did restart checkpoint and
it's like the mission's gone that's so
strange that it would just take the
mission away
I'm still leaning towards some some user
error that I I messed something up but I
really am not sure what
oh we got a cash nearby
oh we're close we're close
what's up
come on is it oh my God
is it inside somewhere oh look at this
oh wait
there it is
yeah that was that was definitely a
different one A different mission that
opened up
what the heck
what are you doing here
it's the last one
do you eventually heal over time because
look at that my health is really low
oh really no way
there we go
anything in this one
doesn't look like it
okay there's another new activity
available yes here we go
it's back
the feast toy stolen
we are going to get this one
I am determined this is the one I want
we're going right back exactly where we
just came from but it's okay
it's okay
yeah so L1 plus X is the Venom jump to
gain height
s
here we go it's on the front Okay
Spider-Man there was a car
we had a couple hundred missing think
somebody stole them
but today we're supposed to have two
trucks out making pickups but our GPS
transponders say there are three
something's up
sounds like you got yourself a poem
that's so weird how am I going gonna
know which one it is
if you can check their license plates
we'll know which one shouldn't be out
there
you can count on me then
Genki there are three Feast trucks out
in the city and one of them now watch
use your help here
see we still can't move
try it on that truck
oh my gosh that's what it was dude it
was blocking it it works
all right I'm glad it wasn't something I
was doing right now
take pictures of the truck's license
plates all right
which by the way we unlocked that
get those back for the kids invisibility
how do I actually use that
let me look and see if we have if it's a
new skill
camouflage yes here we go
camouflage energy refills faster but I
don't it the game didn't even teach me
how to do this
at least I don't think so
unless I missed it maybe I missed it
hmm
you wish Xbox was able to play new
Spider-Man
well they're eventually they'll I think
they'll almost certainly bring it to PC
at some point like they did the last one
just a matter of how long how long it
will be
but yeah don't don't ever see it being
on Xbox
[Music]
unless something really crazy happened
oh so they're moving we gotta catch them
while they're moving
so far off
there's one just need to snap the plate
there we go
is that good enough
legit keep looking all right that one
was legit
you guys already know it's gonna be the
last one we checked right
isn't that how it always works
it's the last one
all right line it up just right clear
picture
boom got it now for the Moment of Truth
yeah oh wow okay
I actually did get it
wait what are we supposed to do
yeah you should be ashamed
stealing toys for kids
take pictures of Dock Workers to find
Joe sounds like they're stealing
into a deal and this Joe is the one in
charge
I'm not gonna find him
okay
I still gotta use camera if I'm gonna
get in close
that close enough
oh he's gotta use camo okay wait how do
I use camo
all right we gotta figure it out guys
controller layout
uh swing and Sprint Venom
camouflages up on the d-pad okay
all right and then does it does it run
out oh yeah I see I see I see
no dice
gonna need a clear shot of the face what
how was that not a clear shot
I was literally right in front of him
oh
that first try
let's go
there must be tires once they're
together you
okay
get on the top of my butt kicking list
dude ripping off their door
getting paids all that matters
up
actually I took the Spider-man oath so I
think I can speak for him here
oh there's another guy
this is Spider-Man oh
all right now we gotta find the toys
oh this truck okay
the truck we couldn't find
oh geez
Big Boy in there
okay he's good
you know what let's get that yeah let's
see that's the little Hollow drones
yeah
I haven't been using them as much lately
ow
e
both of them in one strike
is that it oh you're still up no way
no way you're still up
is that it now we good now we good
but they're all safe and sound at the
dock
the doctor nice all right mission
accomplished
took us a little bit but we got it
thanks Spidey you saved the holidays
head to the repair shop all right we've
unlocked a bunch of those little uh
tokens or whatever it was called
20 okay see we've got 25 oh dude the
animated suit
that looks so awesome unlocks a suit mod
enemies take longer to break out of webs
unlocked at level eight okay we're not
enough of a high enough level yet we
could unlock this one too homemade suit
unlocks the suit mod increases the
damage of Throne objects what about here
can we unlock anything like
oh these are locked
oh wait we could get these
okay so that one decreases damage from
ranged attacks by 25 percent
is there anything better increases drop
rate for Gadget ammo increases window
for perfect dodging on scan marks
enemies through walls and keeps them
marked as long as stealth mode remains
active
what about this one here what do we have
here
it's a concussive force when underground
weapons are shattered
I still think I like decreases melee
damage we need to unlock that second
slot and so we'll get that at level
eight
yeah I don't think I really want to use
any of them right now
gadgets unlocked through story
progression okay
now this we could do this one increases
Max web shooter ammo capacity by two
yeah I feel like I use that a decent
amount
web shooter ammo refills faster that
would be good to have I don't feel like
I use this one too much so I'm not going
to really put anything into it yet
gravity will
I don't think we've gotten this one at
all have we
had level eight okay so we're gonna get
quite a few additional things at level
eight
camouflage energy refills 20 faster uh
we'll see we'll see how much I end up
using that because right now
only had one situation to use it
hey the underground and rocks on are
fighting near innocent people
dude there is always like
there I don't remember if the base game
was like this man that they always have
so many
so many things popping up at once
[Music]
oh we missed
okay this guy where is he right here
let's get both of these guys
throw that away nice
oh I missed
oh I just saw use the gravity well
Gadget okay there it is let's use it
uh use Venom attacks on eight enemies
use the gravity well to pull eight
enemies okay
well we can get the Venom one right
there
we how did they not pull him why did
that not count
and now I'm out I can't use it again
got him one street side shooter we
didn't get that gravity well
eight enemies you'd have to throw that
right in the middle of a big
group of them
all right let's see now let's
always something to do that's for sure
it's
make our way over here to the next main
mission
so I guess these little activities are
just kind of constantly getting added
I'm not sure if there's a specific thing
that triggers when they get added or
what
all right where is it at
where's it at oh we're really close
right here
two there the crimes in progress it is
just constant
there's no way you could stop them all
I mean you'd never beat the game if you
stopped every crime in progress
another activity available okay so I
guess the activities
becoming available is just
a very frequent thing
all right back to the main mission
you were saying uh there have been other
Spider-Man games on Xbox
yeah there's been a lot of Spider-Man
games through the years
when I remember playing growing up uh
think it was on Super Nintendo and Sega
you guys remember Maximum Carnage
that was a fun Spider-Man game and then
the one on
the one that was in like the the PS2
GameCube era
that was a really good one too I think
that came out with the movie The First
the first Toby Maguire movie
but I I definitely think insomniac's
Spider-Man's
top them all
Roger or welcome in good evening Roger I
don't want to draw attention
how's your day been
all right zip to the vent here we go
let us go inside
hello
man this place is Dusty no one's been
here in a while
oh man look at all this old Tech
this massive stereo up here
speakers
washer dryer
most are film related yeah yeah there's
been a lot of uh Rick's ESU textbooks
a lot of them tied to the films keep
running the shop during the day guy
wasn't stoppable
all right what am I supposed to be doing
it yeah I definitely feel like we need
to do something over there
some kind of meds
used for treating bone marrow decay
whose was this
okay someone break this up recently
roxon ID for Ella Sterling
but the photo is a Finn what the heck
Ella is a decent match for you but that
hair maybe wear a hat
hmm
chat
that we can break through this
oh really can we not break through that
I mean we totally could
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how do we
do it that's the question
not letting me shoot any webs or
anything I can't jump
there's something else we're supposed to
do with this
oh wait wait wait here we go other
things we can examine oh God's sake
wait
Rick was Project Lead
her brother okay her brother
Rick Mason was Project Lead Ellis
Sterling that's not her
but she had
a badge
her face Ella's name
is that it
must be a way to clear out this brick
you're right yeah
oh man Roger I hate to hear that yikes
dude sinus infections they are no joke
I used to get them a lot as a kid
because I had such bad allergies and
then it would turn into
I used to learn into an infection
it was like our own private world on the
men now hey good to hear that
oh my gosh these little machines
just something like so recognizable for
so many of us
all right what the heck am I supposed to
be doing here I know we got to get
through that brick wall why is it not
letting me just
use one of my gadgets or something
oh of course they wanted me to do all
the evidence first or all the little
Clues first
access Finn's computer all right what
else we got in here though
what else do we have
it's like
okay something over here to inspect
Finn must have designed all the
underground's gear funny how we both
started wearing masks
all right here's the computer
video file
it was months ago
effects are just so good
running a test upload
oh they're trying to save him half my
team is sick
Krieger
still want to hit his new form
we need to do this tonight let me
you sure we're ready we have to be
they broke ground in Harlem today out of
schedule poisoning the city to make a
buck they keep cutting corners
ignoring safety reports I can't let them
pervert my work like this Finn
okay first we flush the door then we
wipe all data
you're sure they can't just make more of
this stuff no
as long as we take out the backup Supply
in Jersey too
but without me they'll have no idea how
new phone works
project will be DOA I'll record us
things go wrong video uploads straight
to the bugle perfect
you ready to save New York
ready
second video
damn it no uploads
phone must have been damaged
the way they wanted to upload it
I promise Rick
they were trying to shut the new Farm
project down
something went wrong
that's no location of her phone
if I can track it
like how recent was that
come on
invisible the invisible
you ain't invisible
there we go just in time
can't get the drop on them until they
calm down
out for the count
okay let's go ahead and tag all of these
okay is that five
five enemies all right
oh dude there's one way up there
foreign
so what if I
oh
did not mean to do that I thought I had
the web on
oh of course now
of course this would happen
why does it keep telling me to toggle
camouflage like I'm in the middle of the
fight now what's the point
what's the point right we might as well
just be all in
there we go back to that computer
I'll teach you how to do find her
location maybe I can understand what
happened to Rick
why she became the tinkerer there got a
location
who the heck
what was that
you have suits or mods available for
purchase open the pause menu
level eight let's go that was a big
level
the scientist on new form whoa and it
looks like new form was making him sick
Simon Krieger has been telling everyone
how safe it is is lying Finn and her
brother tried to I'm shocked
prevent further development I'm shocked
Simon would lie
being recorded the whole thing on
but then she lost
yeah yeah don't tell me don't spoil it
don't spoil it
call if you need me we'll do
I'm still I mean I'm TR I feel like I'm
having a little bit of trouble following
the story but I don't think we're
supposed to know all the details just
yet about about her situation and her
brother what's going on there huh
all right but I do want to check and see
now it said we can buy new suits
that's right because we're at level
eight now let's go we unlocked a new
suit mod slot okay that's big right
there actually
creates concussive force when
underground weapons are shattered
attacks after a perfect Dodge do 50 more
damage for five seconds that could be
very
very helpful generates a small amount of
Health per hit
on Venom stunned enemies
I feel like that would be super useful
I'm gonna do that one
all right now let's check
okay so which ones could we buy
we could buy that one we just don't have
enough uh tokens for it right now
okay that one unlocks at level nine
Crimson Cal
M oh Christy it's really good yeah I'm
enjoying it which I knew I I knew I
would because I uh I played the the
first one and this one's kind of like
it's like sort of a sequel but
it's not like a full sequel sort of like
a Spider-Man 1.5
because it's not as long of an
experience
but uh yeah I knew I would I would most
likely enjoy it
okay so this one we just unlocked we
don't have it enabled yet we haven't
purchased it but allows a second
finisher to be banked reduces combo
requirement for a second finger oh yeah
this would be very useful
special enemies can be defeated with two
finishers yeah let's do that
and then this right here finishers
generate 40 percent of a Venom bar
old triangled to yank and throw guns
imbued with bioelectric power it will
explode on impact Venom stunning and
knocking enemies down
interesting very very interesting
oh dude all these little Collections and
stuff too
we got a little character thing going
here
oh this is Handy if you forget like
exactly who's who
all right I think we're good for now
even though we still do have one skill
point I'm just I'm still not sure how
much I'm gonna
use the camouflage stuff
see what does this one unlock after
landing press X during a roll to launch
back into the air web zip with X a
second time without losing altitude
when throwing an enemy rapidly press oh
I need to unlock that one too let's do a
combat challenge
it's actually a good one
let us do a combat challenge which what
is the okay that's the fist
where is the fist
of course it's way up here it's all
right we can fast travel to right here
Dr sherbet oh my goodness it has to be
so late for you or so early
welcome in you're still sick Christy oh
my oh my gosh
I mean I'm not even gonna say it because
I don't want to jinx
I don't want to jinx our family we went
through so many
back to back to back to back sicknesses
through our house but
knock on wood been doing doing okay for
a bit allergies are getting
allergy season is really kicking in
strong right now though
okay so 50 hits is the ultimate 25
spectacular 10 amazing
unlock the spin cycle
let's do it
still live Cloud Roth
yes sir
don't use your fist
but I can't punch
okay hit enemies with objects during the
wind up of a web throw to increase your
score ah okay but I can't punch
he definitely said I can't punch didn't
he
okay hold okay yeah
oh nice
I'm a little confused like
that one I am so confused
I gotta get more people to come out than
this right
okay hold on I think he just gave us a
hint right there
[Music]
I don't want to use the finisher though
do I
stop it
okay we got the 25 but we need
we need 50 for the ultimate
hmm
try extending your wind up before
release
I mean I feel like my problem there was
that there weren't enough
guys
but maybe we need to like wait and let
them kind of gather around first
like okay hold on
oh
maybe I just need to be faster
I see right now there's only
oh you don't have anything okay let's
wait a second
no I want to take your weapon right
there
okay I'm not sure if I'm supposed to be
faster
or if I'm supposed to take my time and
let a bunch of them
props I'm just gonna do a finisher see
if it
yeah that that was a waste right there I
shouldn't have done it
yeah this is this is a weird one
[Music]
this is a weird one man we've got to get
50 hits
so we already had almost 30.
all right I'm gonna try to go really
fast this time
I'm gonna focus on
stop it
yeah it counts it counts number of hits
there we go so when you get a bunch of
them kind of surrounding you like that
yeah see we're already up to 20 again
oh that's so good oh 28 28.
I know I'm about to die but I can't heal
actually yeah you can in this
no I need more enemies
dude I don't know how you're gonna get
50.
I'm gonna throw that in my delts
tomorrow
oh yeah I'm gonna for sure play uh
Survivor at some point sherbet I'm just
gonna wait for a few more patches
wait for a few more patches so it's in
like Prime uh Prime condition
oh dude you can actually
okay see that was a waste right there
that one didn't hit anybody
okay come on Gather Round Guys
gather around
hey stop it
[Music]
oh here we go here's a bunch
okay we got three over here
[Music]
almost got there challenge failed what
the heck happened oh did I die
I think I died
Spider-Man stop talking you're
distracting me dude
foreign
guys seen some things okay see when you
take
come on gather around me gather around
me guys
yes
oh see that got a bunch right there
gather round gather around
other round
can you all see me
can you all hit me very satisfied if
anybody should know that reference it
should be this group
40 40
. oh that was so close 42.
uh
[Music]
yeah I've heard PS5 is kind of uh right
now the best running of the of the group
hit enemies with web throw windups
stop it
all right
now no
okay we got the trash can right there
come on surround me guys surround me
yeah I think you're almost better off
like letting them
get around you just like that
and it looks like they do keep giving
you
items to throw oh this is perfect right
here yes that was perfect
no 34 yeah
didn't do as good that time
oh you can never get ultimate on this
one Daniel yeah like I just don't know
what the trick is if it's to go really
fast or if it's to go slow but wait
until they kind of gather around
okay that was terrible
okay that was that was good right there
that got six
okay the last one doesn't even count
it's like it only counts when it's
spinning around
foreign
like see that only gave me one right
there
why is that only giving me one
that gave me two
people all right let's wait till they
gather
gather gather
oh that was big right there when you get
them electrified like that
seated we got so much risk it and let
them surround you yeah that's kind of
what I'm thinking
see like right here at the beginning
yeah look at that you get seven right
there with that
that's definitely the trick
no don't do that
okay why that one only give me 11.
all right all right we'll take it
okay
come on come on surround me surround me
he's got to tell me where that building
is
the Queens
see when you let him get in too close
then then you start to
you lose health
this one is just strange
I almost feel like it's a matter of luck
all right I say two more tries two more
tries
okay that time we got eight on the first
one
see we're just not we don't have enough
of them around over here
oh there's so many right there there's
so many crowded around
I only have 18 seconds though
yeah yeah surround me
36.
37.
oh
all right I want to try something might
need an upgrade that's a good point too
I'm gonna see if punching them does
anything I don't think it does
yeah that's why he said you can't really
oh that was good though
dude maybe you're supposed to use the
punching though to sort of
get them in the right spot
oh there's so many there's so many
there's so many
how did that not get me more
dude look they're all right here
oh 40 40.
44.
45 come on come on come on
50.
yes let's go
oh my gosh 51.
wow okay so it was it was a combination
of
speed but also precision
and lining them up just right
dude that was crazy
imagine if we gotten stuck at at a 49
right there
okay so the good news the reason we did
that
it unlocked spin cycle
blankets or food yeah this thing right
here
when throwing an enemy rapidly press
triangle during the throw
that's good
press triangle after a perfect Dodge
against Rifle and Pistol shots for an
instant takedown
I think we should do that one next
so that just means another combat
challenge
way over here all right let's mark you
fast travel
using the subway station
the Stanley Easter egg no no
where's it at I actually just started
playing
tonight for the first time
I feel like they're Stan Lee he has a
lot of uh
game not not just gaming Easter eggs but
his little cameos and such
all right
unlocks the skill Payback
okay so oh dude this one you can't get
hit donations
zero hits for ultimate one hit for
spectacular two hits for amazing let's
see if there's any sort of special
stipulations or if it's just survive
basically
part of the Dodge okay
three hits and you'll have to restart
all right we're gonna throw immediately
actually you take this
where they at where they at
perfect Dodges will stun enemies
temporarily
that's a lot of guys
foreign
oh they're too far away
Dodge Dodge
last wave oh my gosh I thought we were
almost done
no
yeah
oh my gosh we're so close
is that it is that it is that it
let's go no hits nicely done first try
too right first try
you can one hit KO enemies after a
perfect Dodge now gotta try that out
that's pretty Epic
so basically Dodge and then triangle
Dodge triangle
wait is this something oh yeah that's so
you can repeat it I guess if you want
all right all right all right okay
that's good so skills
we almost I mean
kind of feel like we need to just go
ahead and do the last one air attacks
deal additional damage and generate more
Venom yeah let's go for it
let's go for it it's actually pretty
close by too
go ahead and fast travel right here
put us not far at all
oh wait wrong way
dude I just like it's almost impossible
now for me to go back
to 30 FPS games
it's gonna be hard playing Zelda here in
a few weeks
I'm sure it'll be awesome but man after
you get used to these silky smooth frame
rates
all right so let's see what we have here
I need 10 air Kos
no way
so five air Kos just to start
all right so this I mean
depends on how many people there are
airborne
oh that's crazy
use air launch or swing kick all right I
feel like air launches
probably the best bet
wait did that one not I don't think I
took him out
dude
okay so you basically have to
we need to we need to get them a little
bit weak first
before we do it
there we go
we got three yeah this is gonna be tough
there's only 16 seconds left
does that countless in there yes it does
right way more control up here
oh dude this is gonna be tough
we didn't even get the we did not even
get oh we just did right at the very end
we got the base one
all right here's what I want to see does
it count
okay that's cool so it does go ahead and
unlock it as long as we pass it
so the only point in going for the
get those Bad Dudes off their feet
only point in going for the maximum one
is that you get more uh of those little
tokens or whatever
don't forget in the air you can web them
to keep them in the air do you mean like
the R1 web or like the triangle web
oh I see yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oh did I lose him I lost him
[Music]
you could listen to Pete's Spider-Man
shot talk all day dude is good at this
job
oh and then you can do your finisher in
the air too yeah that's clutch
[Music]
that hands catch
no
no don't start crawling what the heck
oh man
we got stuck in this corner over here
messed everything up let's restart
no launch him
oh yeah and then you can do that too
right after that oh that was sick
okay got him
oh that was it
all right I'm good with that for now I'm
good with that oh we didn't even get the
seven no did you get the seven all right
I gotta at least get the seven
we gotta at least get the seven guys
it's gonna see does that like launch
them into the air
like a skydiver
sity
where's the other guy
you could listen to Pete Spider-Man
okay got him
it's whenever you get hit it really
slows you down
what you just shot your own guy
oh come on
get him
yes okay we at least got the silver
all right all right at least got the
silver
whew
Zelda's like a decade yeah well in some
ways in graphically and performance wise
yes but in every other way
oh man it's just like it's just so good
like the gameplay and everything
okay let's do
what is the next Story Mission we have
here
corporate Espionage that is our next
main mission
[Music]
Hello friends and welcome to the Danica
it is so hot in my office right now
dude the back of the PlayStation 5.
I don't think it's just mine
I think they all put out some heat I'm
in a relatively small room
and you put your hand behind this
PlayStation five dude it is it is like a
space heater
seriously doubles as a space heater I
think it puts out more heat than my PC
research labs
this is where the whole new form project
got started
thins phones in there somewhere yeah I
think Wind Waker holds up to
and I think I just found my way in
how convenient
that Finn has high bolted shooting I
wonder what powers it
got a scan for Clues
okay wait before we do anything
is he safe
he is safe
for us to engage
all right let's do that get you over
there
oh yeah you're you're still danger no
way now you're safe
see this is the kind of stealth I love
man
is that it now to get into the building
you can charge things up
I wonder if I can power things down too
all right how would we do that same way
nope
different way it's like he's absorbing
it
I never played at the HD one Roger I'm
sure it ran a lot better though
do you still have your Wii U by any
chance I I got one at launch but that
was probably my least played system ever
that I that I like bought
so I I ended up trading it in at some
point
but there were actually some pretty
solid games on the Wii U
H breaking into a lab full of armed
guards Christmas break sure is different
this year
naps
playing a ton of video games
100 Christmas
oh no yeah which way exactly dude
let's try this one
I'm wondering if like this vent is this
where we're supposed to go
I still have a Wii but I don't have my
Wii U
hey Christy good to see you as well have
a good night
or a circle to drop
zoom's gonna get musty
dude where the heck are we
getting close right I think that was the
right way
tracker said the phone was pretty far
below ground level
I feel like I'm uh in Mission Impossible
or something
[Music]
if it's underground kill them
everything
oh gosh they they actually kept going
no way
okay now what where are we supposed to
go
infiltrate the lab all right
cutscene time there he is
Prowler
that's so funny
damn miles we're skinny ass kid you hit
hard also he reveals it right away
no and I bet you got a lot of questions
right now but we need to get out of here
you picked the wrong place to break into
I'm not leaving uh-oh
so he's kind of looking out for him
I did some work for Roxanne a while back
you don't want to mess with these guys
if we get caught in here then help me
father
all right but we do this my way
I know a place I can access a security
terminal let you know what's coming
remote Minds
use them if you get in a jam that was
the thing that it said we would unlock
it caught
[Music]
oh I like this I like this shielding
how'd you do that I've worked with
systems like this before now Focus looks
like a good time to try out those remote
mines well R1
okay remote mine gotcha the remote mic
can be used to shock a group of enemies
or to overload highlighted fuse boxes
for bonus damage
okay right there
uh I mean maybe right in the middle
so we got a nice little radius there
it's not quite gonna get that guy unless
hold on
I was trying to shoot right there
to get his attention but he got him
anyway let's go
track the signal
coming from some
selling the ground
it's where I'm headed
oh he's safe
let's get him really quick
oh dude that guy
no wait you didn't see that
no way
how do you access Photo mode in this
game is it
the only the start menu
is I have seen some absolutely
incredible
photos of this game
I mean some of the some of the shots
that people have gotten incredible like
a new form reactor is what these
schematics say yeah
forget I'm struggling up there
all right so we can't do anything there
oh no no no no that's not what I want to
do
zip to the vent
Hey where's the new form I asked for oh
we're trying to make more but Mason
didn't leave behind any notes and well I
have dude that looks like a young Doc
Ock survived the uh incident from the
first game
don't you think that if I had it I would
give it to you yes Mr Krieger I just
want to make it clear that without that
canister it will be impossible to hit
the deadline
I'm doing everything in my considerable
power to find that canister however
right now it would help me for you to go
back to your lab
and this guy is super Pleasant
Krieger's on a deadline
so you're gonna tell me whose phone
you're looking for tinkerers
you're gonna tell me why you're stalking
me to protect you you should feel honest
I came out of retirement to watch your
back can't believe
Fair Point
you're close to the reactive prototype
you could just you know talk to her
all right web strike takedown or workers
comp no Roxanne
all right let's see if we can get a
couple of them over here
go investigate
oh no
no way
they actually saw me
oh Point Blank Range
dude am I really not getting a perfect
Dodge on any of these
because remember if I get a perfect
Dodge I can do like the let's try it
nope okay wait wait wait
I guess you gotta wait
to the last second
let's go
all right well that didn't go exactly as
planned
we took care of it
wait a second
there's more labs around the city
with a new form reactor in each one new
Farm made Rick sick
I need to shut these down
oh my gosh more things on the mat for us
to go around and do Focus
oh you gotta wait for a red to do the
perfect Dodge okay
so you can't get it at all on the just
the white ones
or does it eventually flash red if you
don't do anything
they know someone messed with that
computer you need to go
react is below whoa
's all the way at the bottom there are
so many people
the phones of course it's in like the
most
ridiculous spot
all right this time he said don't get
caught so I think we might have to do
this one stealth
are you safe
you safe yes or no
danger okay
all right let's go ahead and scan
everybody
yeah there is a lot of people in this
room
you got to recreate your characters what
are you talking about
you guys talking about Hogwarts
okay should I go down there
I think so
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
yeah I don't like this I need to be
higher up
yeah we gotta clear it from like top
down
all right let's see we might be able to
get
yeah yeah yeah
oh come on we need that other guy to get
over there too
and Booms
okay I don't know why you're saying
danger there's nobody oh yeah that guy
okay he's safe he's safe he's safe
which means now this guy should be safe
yep he is
just calling to make sure you're not
hurt bro not a good time not a good time
thanks
the subway worker guy
turns out he's also the prowler
long story wait safe let's go
purple
I'm not partnering it's just a one-time
thing you're uncles
that's a lot man like a lot a lot I know
oh come on it's not that crazy
later I am Spider-Man after all
right how many more we got two okay
you're safe
oh the Harry Potter d d thing I was like
what are you guys talking about I have
to remake my character
okay they're both danger because they
are side by side
he is safe no way he's safe
which means now you're safe
all right Uncle I think we did it
is that it
stop thanks
okay hold on
now for the wires
all right
that it nice there we go okay dude how
how did her phone get down here
no way
battery needs a charge
of course and it's dead
okay dude you should have just waited
video
here it is
core dumps a two-person job
you start to override here I confirm it
there step one and wiping new form from
existence any regret
destroying the thing you made
me lately right
right let's make the world safer
ready let's make the world safer okay so
why is she triggering override
I guess we're about to see
that wasn't me
industrial sabotage Rick really
No One's Gonna care about a few sick
people Uptown or a dead engineering
you're just the cost of doing the
business
[Music]
break it down
whoa hold on is he about to come become
shocker or Electro
or is that too much is that like too
many people people
have to finish what they started we
didn't see him die
Where You Are
why you got your phone now
now it needs to be shut down permanently
I need your help uncle
uh Uncle Aaron
okay
stand back
thanks though
all right now what
disable the new form reactor
yo
[Music]
what are you doing
you gotta get out of there man can you
move yeah
go down that hallway now
oh my gosh dude look at the effects
bad right now he's right
all right I don't think the phone can
survive that
is playing
but at least the reactor's disabled
you're almost out
I really needed that phone
now what am I gonna do come on kid I
can't get you before rocks on does
oh
here we go
City new enemy type we got some Shields
here
Old Triangle to disarm
okay so kind of like the
oh my gosh that was crazy
the finishers just look so good in this
yeah
oh no way look at him look at him
they're quick watch how fast he turns
around
all right fine fine we'll disarm you
what
rocks on enemies have special Venom
suppression Technologies some attacks
will apply a suppression effect that
will prevent miles from using Venom
abilities for a short time no way
[Music]
boom
yeah
was it just one guy let's go of course
not oh there he is okay
work
oh we're gonna fight together let's go
don't worry we can take these guys I
ain't worried about that I'm worried
about Apple to get out of here
I have no idea
oh my gosh dude
okay this is actually kind of tough in
here right now
yikes who is that
that guy over there was absolutely
wrecking me
finish him finish him finish him
oh dude a Duo finisher that was sick
and you get to fight alongside Prowler
that's pretty Epic
what does that matter
oh
yeah
okay
oh my gosh another dude
what is this
oh that's our Escape
that's our way out of here
he's about to get a Stern talking to
you don't trust anybody and don't take
off that mask
wait till Roxanne finds a better talk I
can't lay low I still need to find Finn
your friends that tinker
no wonder you care so much about this
it's not just that
I'm
protecting New York is my job
tell her you want to join
a joke tell her you're Spider-Man
go to her dude that's what I said just
ask her
people get stupid when they care about
someone
like you're being stupid now
I told her the truth I told your dad the
truth
how do you have my back
the wood
be my brother
instead he cut me out
if I kept my mouth shut maybe I'd still
have a family
you know what you have to do
hmm
foreign
I know I've said it like five times now
but such a different story from okay
into the spider-verse
no no
I've got time I'm kind of digging this
one right now to be honest
remember to check the friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man app to see new
activities
I've been running some numbers and I
know you said no to ads before but me
should be considered no right no of
course not no ads for us miles
so did you find Finn's phone
yeah but uh it melted after I absorbed
energy from a new form reactor but what
it felt like it was for a minute there
but then I release all the energy in
kind of a mini explosion
luckily I didn't bring down the whole
lab man yeah we've been doing some of
the side quests already so what's
Aaron thinks I should tell Finn I want
to join the underground
so she doesn't use it for whatever
all right you done talking
you have suits or mods all right let's
see what we unlocked here
okay we could yeah I don't I don't know
why that was showing up
I don't want to buy anything else right
now
see
unaffordable we need more of those
activity tokens
oh
oh that's I
I can't decide if that's if I love this
or meh
parts of it I really like parts of it I
don't love
it's always hard for me in these games
to go for something that's just like the
classics are usually just so good
like this one right here
and then this one the one the classic
one for miles
yeah they're just already already too
good the advanced Tech I don't really
love the look of that one though to be
honest
all right let's see let's check in on
our skills here increases Venom oh yeah
absolutely I don't only have two skill
points right now
really thought we'd have a lot more than
that
but yeah I saw you guys talking about
magic awaken you all have to let me know
how it is
I
I still can't believe their weird sort
of launch the way they're handling the
launch of that game
how is it not in the US or UK yet
I mean unless they're just afraid
they're just gonna have such a huge
massive influx of players is all I know
all right let's make sure we we save I
have not I've not done a manual save at
all we've been doing all
um is that it did it
okay yeah there we go
yeah I think that's gonna be where we
call it tonight guys
I think I'm gonna have to call it there
man we just put in
a four and a half hour stream
four and a half hour stream but guys if
you uh catch this on the replay and you
make it all the way through to the end
make sure you uh let me know let me know
in the comments replay Squad
appreciate you guys all being here
hanging out tonight this has been fun
might do more uh gameplay streams over
here on YouTube see the thing that I
love about doing it here is the vods
there now so
it's like I don't even need the separate
let's play Channel whenever I do them
live here
if I do them live on Twitch then I want
to bring them over but I don't want to
put them on the main it's a whole thing
right
um but yeah I am going to commit to I'm
gonna do this is a shorter game So the
plan here is all of the Spider-Man
streams will be on YouTube
so if you guys are catching this later
and wondering there will be more
episodes
I heard the games about 10 hours in
which we played four and a half hours
tonight so
we kind of talked a little bit in the
beginning so we didn't start right away
so let's just say we got a good three
and a half hours in
so we're probably maybe around a third
third of the way through the game so
maybe
maybe two or three more Spider-Man
streams we'll keep those here on YouTube
um but yeah man thank you guys all for
being here like I said if there are any
weird glitches or Cuts I'm hoping that
we don't get hit with copyright on some
of the music in the game but we'll see
we'll see if we do we'll we'll cut it
out and that'll be it
yeah I am a night owl surprised it ran
this late yeah JP one like once I get
going on a game if I'm really into it
honestly even during the day when we do
our streams over on Twitch I would keep
going but usually I have to get off for
like when my kids get home we'll eat
dinner and then they usually have
baseball practice or something that
we're doing that evening so
yeah when I stream at this hour it's
just like
I have to force myself to hop off
definitely bedtime
well Roger let's see Roger JP who made
it to the end here we got Jenny Dr
sherbet Roger Nico is still here in the
house I see Kevin as well
was just here still a moment ago Cloud
Roth was here pretty recently
seven in the morning oh my gosh Kevin
that is crazy
lebano libano libano
probably mispronouncing that terribly
yeah thank you guys so much for the
support all the new uh members we had a
quite a few gifted memberships tonight
too I don't know if we had I don't know
if we had anybody subscribe or not I
don't think maybe I don't have that set
up but I don't remember seeing any
any subscribers
but um if we did Welcome in guys thank
you all for being here hope you all have
a fantastic rest of your week uh we'll
see I don't know when we'll be back but
I definitely want to play this again so
and I'm trying not to start a bunch of
games like I did before I'm trying to
finish games so we're gonna try to get
through this one before we start
anything new especially before we start
like Jedi survive or something like that
so uh all right I've talked long enough
I've rambled you guys have a great one
and I will talk to you again soon
later later later